they are so
cute and they even smell like the cereal
y'all crocs the colorful shoe that first
became popular in the early 2000s hit
its peak in 2021. the company reported a
record annual revenue of 2.3 billion
dollars in 2021 up over 60 percent from
the previous year and its stock reached
record highs the past few years for
crocs has been this moment of
heavy collaboration constant releases
they're really trying to put themselves
in front of people that might not have
considered crocs prior
the company's success coincided with the
pandemic leading some to credit the
shoe's popularity to timing especially
as its stock price has been dropping
since the pandemic boom has waned but
other comfortable footwear brands didn't
take off the way crocs did so how did
crocs make a name for itself during the
pandemic and how did it find success as
one of fashion's most divisive shoes
this is the economics of crocs
the company was founded in 2002 the same
year it debuted its classic clog the
name crocs was inspired by crocodiles
who live on land and in water when
crocks were first released they were
intended for a consumer that was looking
at them as a functional thing so
probably gardeners people that you know
were on boats people that worked all day
on their feet people that worked on a
line in the kitchen part of what makes
them so functional is the material a
proprietary closed cell resin called
crosslight that's slip resistant
lightweight and easy to clean producing
a molded shoe is certainly simpler in a
lot of ways than assembling a sneaker
the most underrated advantage they have
over the marketplace is that it's clear
that they're able to kind of do things
that other companies would not be able
to do because of their scale and because
of their production capabilities crocs
sales took off in the first three
quarters of 2005 it sold 4.4 million
shoes hitting a revenue of 75 million
dollars
part of the reason for its initial
success was that the shoe was easy to
get it was available at retail stores
gift shops and mall kiosks in 2006 crocs
purchased jibits a company that made
small plastic shoe charms that same year
the company went public and became the
largest ever us footwear ipo at the time
but in 2008 in the midst of the
financial crash the company suffered a
net income loss of 185 million dollars
though the initial craze had simmered
the brand still managed to hang on to a
relatively large customer base over the
next few years thanks to its global
presence in 2014 crocs started making
major changes to its business model
closing dozens of stores shifting away
from malls and turning to online sellers
like amazon crocs announcing today it
will eliminate nearly 200 jobs and close
a number of retail stores as part of a
restructuring effort the company also
cut back on the number of styles it sold
by between 30 and 40 percent and
refocused on the classic clog that made
it famous
the following year crocs invested in a
global marketing push to relaunch its
brand image
despite its efforts the company's stock
held steady until 2020 when the global
pandemic hit prior to people working
from home and you know not wearing their
dress shoes not wearing their heels
there was already this rising wave of
comfort minded comfort first footwear
that was really becoming more popular of
course that accelerated during the
pandemic the comfort aspect is what many
call the key to crox's success but
another important factor is how easy it
is to customize the shoe with gibbets
you could move them to different crocks
over time as you've got a green pair a
camo pair or a pink pair that like the
gibbets would stay with you and they
were yours they were almost like
the way a keychain on a backpack was at
a certain point this idea of
individuality and self-expression is one
that the brand emphasizes through its
marketing campaigns
and on social media the uniqueness of
the shoe's design has sparked debate
even going back to crocs early days
there were two warring factions of crocs
are ugly and they're a blade on society
and we need to get rid of them i don't
care how comfortable they are they're
ugly and then there were people that
said no they're cute and they're kind of
doughy and they're fun look how freaking
you these are crocs leaned into this
polarization partnering with celebrities
and well-known brands to create limited
edition versions of the classic clog i
think that's probably the biggest shift
within the fashion world of the past
decade is that people truly seem to
design for instagram because you want to
stop people from scrolling and certainly
a shoe plastered with fried chicken does
that in 2018 crocs says it's balenciaga
clog an 850 dollar four inch platform
shoe sold out within hours and in 2021
crocs says it partnered with more than
two dozen brands artists and creators
through collaborations and license
programs sometimes it was through
gibbets but sometimes it was like these
kind of crazy revamping of what their
clog was constantly releasing new
collaborations has not only kept crocs
in the press but it has also helped it
break into new markets there are like
croc collectors that go after every
model penny i am overflowing with crocs
the same way that nikes resell on
websites like stockx and ebay crocs are
now reselling crocs and other
comfortable shoes may have peaked with
the pandemic as people begin to migrate
back into work and consider more
traditionalist footwear but many others
are still prioritizing comfort we're
seeing that with a lot of doughy running
sneakers that people are wearing we're
seeing that certainly with the growth of
slides is a huge business in the luxury
market crox's stock has dropped around
60 percent since its november 2021 high
i think the market's nervous about the
short term right so we're definitely
seeing supply constraints in the first
quarter
but the company says its fourth straight
year of revenue growth was fueled by
continued global demand and it expects
revenues to grow to over 5 billion
dollars by 2026. i think that they might
plateau at a certain point you could
only reach so many consumers but i think
for now
they have been able to convince enough
consumers that they deserve space within
their closets
[Music]